joining us now Treasury secretary
Stephen minuchin is a member of the
president's coronavirus task force mrs.
secretary welcome back to Fox News
Sunday Thank You Chris it's good to be
back with you President Trump says that
once the country reopens that we're
going to see a sharp quick recovery here
he is this week we're gonna rebuild it
and we're gonna rebuild it better and
it's going to go faster than people
think
I built it once I built it a second time
how sharp a recovery do you see and how
soon sir well Chris I think as we begin
to reopen the economy in May and June
you're gonna see the economy really
bounce back in July August September and
we are putting in an unprecedented
amount of fiscal relief into the economy
you're seeing trillions of dollars
that's making its way into the economy
and I think this is gonna have a
significant impact but that quick bounce
back that you talked about goes against
the forecast of most experts and take a
look at these numbers sir the
nonpartisan Congressional Budget Office
now projects GDP will shrink by 5.6
percent total this year unemployment
will end 2020 day project close to 12
percent and your former company goldman
sachs says the global hit will be four
times worse than the 2008 Great
Recession question are all those
independent experts wrong well Chris
we've never seen anything like this this
is this is not the financial crisis this
is a scenario where we've closed the
economy and we're going to open the
economy so all these models are based
upon health assumptions how quickly we
reopen so we'll say my own opinion is
again we have unprecedented amount of
liquidity in the system
we're very sympathetic to all the people
that are out of work but there is
enhanced unemployment there's the PPP
there's direct deposits this is going to
put a lot of liquidity and as businesses
begin to open you're gonna see demand
side of the economy rebound
let's talk about the PPP the president
just signed a bill that Congress had
passed another three hundred ten billion
dollars for the Paycheck protection
program but the first round that was two
hundred and fifty three hundred billion
dollars the sign up for that ran out in
thirteen days how long do you think this
next tranche of 310 billion dollars is
gonna last and can you guarantee that
big corporations for instance like
Ruth's Chris that got money the first
time around eventually paid it back but
that get money won't even get money this
time
Chris I just want to put this in
perspective and I want to thank
everybody the SBA and the Treasury
because we launched a brand-new program
in an incredibly short period of time
and the fact that we ran out of money
just goes to show the success of this
now let me put this in perspective in
the first round over a million companies
had workers of ten people or below and
there has been a lot of focus on these
big bigger companies public companies we
came out with new guidelines we made it
clear they shouldn't have applied
they're paying back the money so I think
you're gonna see this move in the right
direction and I think you're gonna also
see in this round the the average loan
size go down significantly but to my
other question which was that the money
and for the first program lasted less
than two weeks how long do you expect
this money to last
Chris to me it's not it's not a matter
of how long it lasts the the actually I
think the sooner the money is dispersed
the better so the first round impacted
about 30 million workers I think this
round will be about the same that'll be
close to 50 percent of the private
workforce so I actually hope we run out
of money quickly so we can get the money
into the workers pockets and again in
this round
we're making it clear that small
businesses have access we've signed up a
lot of CDFIs we're signing up more of
them so we're gonna make sure that this
is distributed fairly
Congress is already talking with all the
money that's already been dispersed is
talking about yet another relief bill
and one of the big issues there is
whether or not to give five hundred
billion dollars in relief to state and
local governments so that they can
continue to pay first responders and
other workers and to provide services
this week Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell and New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo split sharply about that take a
look sir I would certainly be in favor
of allowing Stacey is the bankruptcy
route it saved some cities he says maybe
the states should declare bankruptcy
okay this is one of the really dumb
ideas of all time does the president
support giving aid hundreds of billion
dollars to the states and what would the
economic effect be if major states like
New York and Illinois were to declare
bankruptcy Chris I first want to just
say I really want to thank the Senate in
the house for the unprecedented
bipartisan support the the bill first
passed 96 dough and this one was
unanimous consent in the Senate so my
comment on this is this will be
something that both the Senate and the
house debate it'll be something that we
discuss on a bipartisan basis the
president has heard from governor's he
wants to speak to governor's this is
something we'll consider but our focus
right now is really on execution and
that's what we're focused on and if we
need more money as I've said this is a
war we'll win this war if we need to
spend more money we will and we'll only
do it with bipartisan support all right
let me pick up on that last point
because with all of the money that's
already gone out the national debt will
by the end of this year exceed the gross
domestic product the total output of the
economy it'll be over 100 percent of GDP
which has always been considered a kind
of redline for stable economies how much
do you worry about a debt in excess of a
hundred percent of GDP
well Chris the good news is that
interest rates are extremely low so if
you look at the portion of the budget
that we're actually allocating to
interest it's extremely low and we're
locking in long term rates to make sure
this additional money we've locked up
for a long period of time over time that
is something we're going to need to look
at and we're gonna need to look at
overtime how we deal with that issue but
right now we're in a war and we have to
protect American workers and American
business and we're gonna do whatever we
need to take to do that in the time we
have left I'd like to do a lightning
round I've done these with you before
quick questions quick answers we see
States starting to reopen if they reopen
too quickly if we see a spike in cases a
second spike how damaging would that be
to the economy I think we have to
balance this in this time with the
advent of testing more testing the
advent of antibody testing I think we're
going to be able to monitor this very
very carefully will the administration
bail out oil companies because as you
well know there are some critics who say
that yes there are problems that came
from the corona virus and the global
drop but a lot of problems of oil
companies were of their own making
before we ever got into this pandemic
Chris let me be very clear the president
has said no bailouts to any companies
whether that was Airlines or oil
companies we will consider again loans
to companies in a proper scenario its
strategic importance but no bailouts no
shareholder bailouts and would you
consider loans to oil companies that we
would and we're looking at it carefully
the Secretary of Energy and I are
studying it and we're looking at it very
carefully
finally some top Republicans are talking
about going after China but to punish
them for their failure to be much more
transparent at the very start of this
pandemic and in fact the Attorney
General of Missouri has already sued
China how do you balance
on the one hand whole wanting to hold
China accountable to hold them
responsible but on the other hand we're
in the middle of a pandemic we're in the
middle of a global economic crisis
wanting to protect global markets
especially global trade well for the
moment we need to work globally to
conquer this virus but the president's
made very clear he wants to understand
what China knew when they knew it and if
they knew things that they didn't turn
over that could have stopped this he
will hold them accountable so at this
point
can you see sanctions strong economic
action against China of course I think
you know we never make comments on
future sanctions options we're gonna
leave it there
secretary minuchin thank you thanks for
your time this weekend it's always a
pleasure to talk with you sir thanks
great to be back with you Chris